we are now starting test seven and we're
on section two let's see problem one
problem one is on page 774.
so they say set x
x is equal to this
33.
i haven't read the problem yet i'm just
drawing with they drew
this is 32
sets x and y are shown above how many
numbers in set x are also in set y well
this is
hopefully fairly straightforward is 30
in set y no
this 31 is that y no 32 is right and so
it's 33
one two answer is two that's choice a
not too tough huh all right problem
number two
if pegged traveled 10 miles in two hours
10 miles in two hours
and linda traveled twice as far and half
the time
so linda linda traveled twice as far so
twice as far as 10 miles so she traveled
to 20 miles right
times two that's all i did and they say
in half the time so she traveled 20
miles in one hour right i just did one
half here 20 miles an hour what was
lindra's average speed in miles per hour
she did 20 miles in one hour well that's
20 miles per hour
20 miles per hour and that's choice c
also
not a difficult problem
not that you should feel bad if you get
it wrong you know it's just all about
practice
it's all about actually reading the
problem
i know that might seem a bit obvious but
you'd be surprised you even see me make
a couple of mistakes by not reading the
problem properly
okay problem three they say and my
cousin marked this up with a black
marker so i only hope that what i see is
what you see so let's see x
is equal to she did this when she was in
sixth grade so
i'm very proud of her that she was
taking the sat in sixth grade anyway x
is equal to k times k
minus 2
then x plus 1 is equal to what
excuse me x plus 1
is equal to what
so this is add 1 to both sides of this
equation so x plus 1 is equal to k times
k minus 2 plus 1.
i just add 1 to both sides of that
equation that equals k squared
okay minus 2k
plus one
and that is
choice
if i can read this properly that's
choice c
k squared minus two k plus one
problem number four
i should have drank water before
starting this video but i will move
forward
move forward and complete what i have
begun
so they draw a graph look something like
it looks something like that and then
there's a line
a line goes something like
this
and then they tell us what do they tell
us they tell us well it looks like they
inter it intersects
it intersects at this point at y equals
one so this is the point zero one right
this is x is zero this is the x axis
this is the y axis
the figure above shows the graph of the
line of y equals ax plus b
y is equal to a x plus b where a and b
are constants
which of the following best represents
the graph of the line
2 a x
plus b
so let's so let's draw it i'm not going
to look at all the choices what would
this look like so it's going to have the
same y-intercept right it's going to
intersect at the same point
that's the y-intercept let me draw it in
this peach color
so it's going to intersect right here
and it's slope is two times the slope of
the previous one so it's going to be
even a steeper slope
so it's the line is going to look
something like this it's going to be
twice as steep
so it's going to look like this
all right and all i said is that same
y-intercept
right because
the b is still b but they double the
slopes it's going to go up even faster
it's going to go up even faster and so
if we look at all the choices
we can immediately rule out all of the
choices that don't have the same
y-intercept and the only choices that
have the same y-intercept are choices b
and c
right only those intersect at 0 1 and
then between b and c b is steeper
so b is are going to be our answer right
c is actually less deep than this green
line
c looks like something like this
choice c looks something like
this so it's slope is less than a so
it's not going to be choice c so it has
to be choice b b goes through the the
same y intercept and it is steeper than
our original
green line so that's the answer choice b
next problem
problem five
okay they drew us a triangle
it's one side
it's another side
they have drawn this oops i can't okay
there you go it's not as
nice looking as i would have liked but
you get the point it's a right triangle
they say that this is x
this is x
and the figure above the perimeter of
the triangle is 4
plus so perimeter is equal to 4 plus 2
root 2. what is the value of x
so what is the value of this side well
pythagorean theorem the value of that
side is the square root of
x squared plus x squared
so that equals what the square root
of 2x squared
you could take the x out right square
root of x squared is just x so that
equals x square root of 2. and they
actually even tell you that on the first
page of of you know if you go back to
page 774 they tell you a 45-45-90
triangle it's s squared so 2. but i like
to solve it every time doesn't it so
this is x this is x this is x squared so
two so what's the perimeter it's x plus
x
plus x
root two so it's two x
root two that's the perimeter right
and they also tell us that that equals
4 plus 2 root 2. right that's for the
perimeter so you can just do pattern
matching you say well this looks a lot
like x is equal to 2 and it is because
if x is equal to 2 this becomes a 2 and
then this becomes a 4
right so that's our answer x is equal to
and that is choice a
next problem
let me switch colors okay so something
for me to draw well before i draw let me
read the question the scores on
tuesday's history test for 16 students
are shown in the table above
sam was the only student absent on
tuesday
he'll take the test next week if sam
receives a 95 on the test what will be
the median score
for the test
okay so they tell us they give us a
score and number of students i'm
actually write all this score
and then number
and so
100 one kid got a hundred
and ninety five
two kids got a ninety five
ninety four kids got it
85 one kid
three kids
two kids
no kids
and then 60
one kid and then sam comes along and
gets a 95 on the exam right
so before there's only two kids who got
a 95 now sam comes along and there's
going to be three kids who got a 95 on
the exam
so to figure out the median all i do is
i list out all the numbers and then i
pick the middle number that's all the
median is
so one kid got a hundred
so one kid got a hundred three kids got
a 95 95
95 95.
four kids got a 90 one
two
three
four
one kid got an 85
three kids got an 80 80
80.
two kids got a 75
75. two kids got a 70
and one kid got a 60. so how many is
that total i could have just added this
that's actually what i should have done
but it's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 15 16 17. so there's 17 kids so the
the median is going to be the number
that has eight above and eight below it
so one two three four five six seven
eight
bam that's the median because there's
one two three four five six no no that's
not the median sorry sorry sorry this is
the median 85 because there's one two
three four five six seven eight above it
and there are 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
below it so the answer is 85 before sam
came in there then the median actually
it actually would be
what you'd have one number less here so
you'd have to move it up so it'd
probably be 90 or it'd be average but
anyway we know the median is 85 and that
is choice c
see you in the next video